[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hey you doing okay there
oh it looks like you're trying to build
an ai system for your factory line
ah i might have a solution i've recently
built
a vr demo that uses google cloud automl
object detection to detect objects on a
conveyor belt
all in real time i've got the whole
thing built in vr
and it sounds like it's similar to what
you're trying to do i could show you if
you're interested
[Music]
cool let's jump right in
all right welcome to our factory floor
you can see we have a conveyor belt
and we have items coming down the
conveyor belt these are items we need to
recycle properly so
all the glass goes into the red bin and
that gets me one point
and then you can see we've got some
organic matter here and that goes into
the green bin
more points there that all is good oh no
okay
we're starting to get quite a lot more
items
what do we do well first let's collect
some training data to build a machine
learning model with
so we have a camera rig here that's
going to take photographs
as the items are coming down the
conveyor belt and they're going to
display them here but they're also going
to save them
for us to import into automotive so
let's go over to automl now
here is the automl interface we've
imported
the images that we just captured and
inside the interface
we're able to go in and draw the
bounding boxes
around each item that we want to train a
model
to detect so i've pre-defined the types
of items
in the ui and i can just go down and
draw boxes and it'll give me a drop down
list
of the different labels for it to learn
this all looks good
we can go out and we can now train a new
model
so we click on train new model
and here is where we specify to train an
edge model
this is going to allow us to download
and deploy our model directly
into our assembly line
we can even inspect the way our data is
going to be used in terms of test data
and training data
and we can even optimize to have a
either more accurate model
or a faster model
and here's where we decide how much
training time to give it and what's
great is if it doesn't need all the time
it will converge early and stop early
so it's going to go off and train all
inside the cloud
and as soon as it's finished it will
send you an email and that's going to
allow you to download it
as a tensorflow lite model
and we can take our model and we can
deploy it directly
into our factory floor so we will do
that
now and now you can see it running in
real time
you can see binding box is being drawn
on the images there
and it is correctly moving the grabber
to put the items all into the correct
bins
so you can see how we're taking our
images and running our model on them all
in real time
so that is how we build a machine
learning model to run
on the edge with automl
right then what'd you think of that
now it's your turn to give it a try
if you're inspired and you want to learn
more check out the links below by add
platform and automl
you